call of duty's stg44 also known as the
mp44 has been in more games than you
probably remember from his first
appearance in call of duty 1 all the way
to vanguard i'm here to take you back
through the years and talk about how the
assault rifle has changed over the
course of 16 games for more call of duty
videos just like this one remember to
subscribe to gamespot let's get started
and here's the game that started it all
this is call of duty 1 from 2003 and the
scg is represented here although not
that much there's only a few levels
where it's actually made available to
pick up off the ground so this one it's
represented classically with the 30
round magazine and the the front iron
sight is rounded there
and the fire rate is pretty normal the
recoil is a little nuts but i'm playing
on pc and i'm not that good so
the stg was also in the united offensive
dlc but i didn't capture gameplay
because it's exactly the same
moving on to call of duty 2 this one was
kind of a fun adventure i tried to get
some online play and didn't get any luck
so i moved on to playing world at war to
get stg footage of that
but as soon as i hopped into world at
war here i got an invite from someone
who's like
yo i have a
i have six you know 3v3 i got a lobby
going do you want to come back and play
so here i am playing
uh six or seven people total i think
eventually joined and
the sdg is back and it looks good it's a
little it sounds a little different but
it plays pretty much the same
and i think it's actually a little
darker but those are the biggest changes
so i got some multiplayer gameplay here
followed by some campaign gameplay so
check it out
wow
moving on to call of duty 2 big red one
this is my ps2 footage which was
actually very dark so i brightened it up
here
and uh i also the first thing i noticed
while picking up an stg here was it does
the full reload every time
so
it's a little longer to reload here
and you know it's a little slower pace
the ps2 my ps2 joysticks and controller
haven't held up the best so
the stg44 or you know the mp44 here is
still a good choice in this game
it's a little easy to find it's i
wouldn't say it's the easiest the mp40
is still just the gun that's laying
around everywhere so when you get your
hands on this gun it's a worthy choice
but the iron sights here don't have the
rounded front sight the games go back
and forth between keeping it and
removing it and i kind of like it it's
just a little stubby
enemies
the stg is also of course in the n-gage
version a version i've played but i
don't have so shout out to the n-gage
video archive it's not a good choice for
a gun it's not a good choice for a game
so watch and you'll see what i mean i
can't
oh god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
martin give me covering fire
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i tried getting a match of call of duty
3's online multiplayer but i had zero
luck so i just jumped into single player
and uh this first mission here after
fighting this guy with uh quick time
events i got the scg right away and this
game was made by treyarch so the designs
are a little different like i believe
most of the assets are are borrowed in
terms of guns but the coloring's
different on this one and the the front
iron side is back and it sounds
different so i'll let you listen here
the full reload also returns even when
you have bullets in your magazine which
is kind of weird takes a little longer
but the gun is still solid and in call
of duty 3 you can find this gun pretty
often the iron sights here are kind of
the standard in my mind because they
remind me of a world that wars stg44 so
it's a it's a good iron sight that isn't
too close to the player's face also
oh
moving on to call of duty roads to
victory this is footage captured
directly from my psp so now we go back
to the iron sight that doesn't have the
rounded end and uh this game just
it it looks like it chugs and it kind of
does but it's much better played on the
actual psp the contrast on that screen
is so much better it's meant to be
played on there obviously also the
controls for this game aren't the best
so thank goodness for the aim assist
that really just sticks to every enemy
like this
the gun placement in this game is really
randomized so it's hard to get an stg44
every time
[Music]
[Music]
nice shooting lad
and of course this is the first modern
appearance of the stg44 i am sort of
familiar with this gun it was a it was
an unlockable as like the last assault
rifle and i always thought that was
weird because it was a pretty
underwhelming gun that you can't put
attachments on but
sounds good i'm using the remastered
version here because finding a match of
cod 4 online on the original xbox 360
version is just not happening
uav recon standing by
our uav is online
here i have a kit attached to it which
was cool it's like the the remastered
version of modern warfare actually lets
you put on kits to your assault rifle
class so i had this one it looks pretty
cool
still no attachments though
[Music]
uav recon standing by
are you a via
here it is of course in world at war
it's a great assault rifle in this game
it looks a little skinnier but it's got
that great like typewriter sound this is
a memorable sounding stg in my opinion
but it's a good gun it's a little bouncy
all the guns in ecology world at war are
kind of like jumpy when you aim down
sights but it's not the worst
[Applause]
of course here it is in zombies for the
first time you can upgrade the stg to
like the spats 44 7. it gets a pretty
nice damage buff of course but it also
gets like a huge magazine look at the
bottom right there
see you maggot bags
here it is in world at war ds this
actually isn't my footage i have the
game but i have no way to capture it at
the moment so this is from retrovamp
over on youtube and honestly it's
probably much better than any gameplay i
could capture for this game these games
on the ds just hurt my hand because you
have to use the stylus so intensely
overall it's just a downgraded version
with slower fire rate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here it is in call of duty world at war
final fronts this is the ps2 version of
world at war the gameplay also was dark
so i had to brighten it up but the scg
performs really well here like there's
no recoil very much in this game and the
fire rate is pretty fast so if you can
find this stg laying around it's a good
choice and it sounds a little
differently too take a listen
coming this way oh we're sitting ducks
here tucker get that damn door open
try it steve got something get it open
now
let's go
here it is featured in black ops this is
the flashback mission where you play
alongside reznov and
the stg here is pretty much a carbon
copy of world at war but it's just
in the updated engine so still a solid
gun for this mission
after this mission do you think we will
go home i hope so dimitri
i hope
oh
do not point that weapon at me
russian dog
here it is in black ops 2 this is the
origins map and it's one of the only
ways in this game you can access the
scg-44
so here it is again pack-a-punch says
the spats 447 and same thing as a world
at war the ammo capacity is like doubled
so it's a great gun it's a great assault
rifle to use in this mode although i
felt like i ran out of ammo pretty
quickly
damn mud slowing me down
you don't need to understand i'm trained
for this
just disappeared
that must have been at least 500 pounds
of explosives right there
here i am in advanced warfare and this
was probably the hardest footage to
capture because even after grinding for
so long in this game i wasn't able to
get a care package with stg in it which
is how you acquire it in this game so
all this footage here is me picking up
other people's stgs on the ground so i
get really campy but despite that it's a
good assault rifle in this game
especially because you can customize it
it's not everyone's favorite assault
rifle there are much better ones but in
my experience it was good
for the first time he can also apply a
camo to it so there were some unique
ones that i picked up off the ground but
i still just wish i had my own
[Music]
ugh
main control
here it is in black ops 3 this is the
shino numa map you can technically pack
a punch this gun
even though this map doesn't have a
pack-a-punch machine if you use one of
the gobble gums you can get this from
the box pack a punched already but of
course i didn't have any of that gum so
here it is stock
[Applause]
it's kind of got that general black ops
3 assault rifle sound which is pretty
quiet even unsilenced take a listen
[Applause]
world war ii is where the sdg felt like
home again obviously it's a world war ii
game but you can customize it here and
it's not just a funny add-on or like a a
relic like an advanced warfare it's very
usable here and was one of my favorites
it's of course also in the zombies mode
so here i am pack-a-punching it this
obviously isn't treyarch zombie so it's
not called the spats 447 like before i
think this time it's just called the
stg770
but sadly there's no special sound
design for this it's really just an stg
with a fancy camo on it
and of course here it is in call of duty
vanguard beta this was a popular choice
for just about everyone everyone was
using the stg myself included uh as far
as ars go it's one of the best it just
reminds me of a well-rounded m4 or
something like that so everyone was
using it and now you can add 10
attachments which is nuts
we took the advantage
capturing charlie
hostile record in the air spies in the
sky
it's a good route
the round is nearly done
if you're a fan of the stg drop a like
and let me know what you'd like to see
next time as well with call of duty
vanguard and new warzone map coming soon
stay tuned to gamespot for more coverage
and videos just like this thanks for
watching
[Music]
you